2023 is the 50th year anniversary of the
release of that album I've spent every
one of those 50 years trying to undo the
damage caused by the title of that
album Chuck got another one okay it's in
our
culture not there's no escaping it some
percentage of people who walk this
earth when asked would be sure that
there's such a thing as the dark side of
the Moon yeah that's where the
Transformers hide
out I thought it just the other side of
the moon all right so the Dark Side of
the Moon I think hit a peak in 1973 do
you know what happened then uh did Pink
Floyd put out an album Pink Floyd put
out an album because that that would do
it and you know the album did really
well see that's the problem if if people
hated the album my job would have been
way easier because no one would have
been brainwashed by it exactly 2023 is
the 50th year anniversary of the release
of that album I've spent every one of
those 50 years trying to undo the damage
caused by the title of that album see
now what you should have done is just
you know you should have took Pink Floyd
out the same way you took out
Pluto would have would not have to worry
about
this get get authoritative
legislation Dark Side of the Moon is now
dwarf Side of the Moon whatever so now
if you if you listen to the title track
like with
headphones the very last sentence the
very last two sentences you know what
they are I do not okay you got to listen
because there's a lot of fadey kind of
music in in all all of those tracks so
you listen and it's f it says at the end
there is no Dark Side of the Moon there
is no dark sight in the moon
really problem solv people just listen
to the song
however there's a sentence that follows
it of course there has to be matter of
fact it's all
doubt
oh oh that's a little more philosophical
that's a little more philosoph yeah yeah
yeah so then I said I can't get on their
case too much here because that's just
being poetic yeah well and but anyhow
there are people who still think that
the other side of the moon never sees
sunlight true which is interesting for
anybody to think that CU you never seen
The Far Side that side of the moon so
why would you even conclude that the
moon does always show the same face to
Earth and talk tital locking that's
right so the other side of the moon gets
as much sunlight as the near side so
there's a far side and a near side and a
day on the moon lasts 30 days 30 Earth
days so there's like 15 days of sunlight
and 15 days of
darkness gotcha so yeah so moon has days
just as we do but so I see had you
thought about it Chuck when you see a
half moon in the sky right wouldn't you
think that like the half you don't see
on the other side is also getting
sunlight right well I mean isn't that
how Shadows
work shadows and round things shadows
and round things kind of work that way
you
know yeah so that should that should
have people should have been tipped off
by that right U
so here's the thing when the Indians uh
landed their had their first successful
landing on the moon becoming the fourth
country to do so from Soviet Union back
in the day and United States by the way
Soviet Union got there first Soviet
Union beat us at everything until we put
humans on the moon then we said we win
so hey man that's how you got that's how
you win you change the rules you change
the gost change move the goal post and
change the rules man put the go post
where you're standing and then you win
so yeah they beat us had the first had
the first satellite the first nonhuman
animal the first human the first woman
and then we were just like none of that
counts Okay C we put the first
dude Russia even had the first black
person who was a Cuban uh he was a Cuban
dark skinn Cuban dark SK Cub right right
so anyhow so we so they became the
fourth country to do this and but what's
more significant than that because that
that would just be okay welcome to the
club all right they landed near the Moon
South
Pole and the South Pole I think we
talked about in a previous explainer uh
you have the bases of craters the Sun
never gets high enough in the sky
because near the poles the sun is stays
low stays so low that sunlight never
reaches the bottom of the crater and so
it's it's literally where the sun don't
shine okay there are literal Dark Places
on the moon right okay all right so
here's the
thing the Indian
spacecraft
landed not in the bottom of a crater
because that's it's it has solar panels
and it needs energy so it landed outside
the crater but in
darkness and so why would they do that
well here's what they did they landed on
the last day of nighttime ah the 30th
day okay on the last day of
nighttime so that the next day the sun
rose and how much daylight do they get
they get 15 days now they get 15 days so
it's a it's a two-e
mission not that was so smart
yes that's really cool so now they have
two weeks to go look for their ice or
whatever and yeah yeah water it be
frozen of course that's right yeah yeah
and so uh yeah it's smart people are
people who figure this stuff out and as
a matter of fact it is rocket science
right because they have to leave Earth
so that they landed there at that time
that's right that's right okay so so oh
so my point is there were some Indian
headlines that said um Chand 3 which is
the name of that mission landed on in On
the Dark Side of the
Moon oh yeah see so they got they got
caught up in that yeah but that wasn't
the Indian Space Program saying that it
was the journalist who correct don't
understand right apparently album had
worldwide influence that I didn't know
about yeah well the album sales could
have told you
that yo what's up Chuck Nice here you
know I'm doing my first first science
themed comedy special now don't worry
I'm not going to try to make you learn
something I stress education so much in
my home my children think that I am an
Indian
parent but if you do learn something
that's totally fine my special is called
Chuck KN just smart enough it's taping
at the midnight theater on November 17th
and 18th here in Manhattan so go to
Chuck comic.com pick up your tickets and
then come to the show and guess what
stupid people are welcome too so I think
they might have seen it landed in the
dark and then moon and the word dark
becomes Dark Side of Mo Dark Side of
Moon wow yeah yeah and so uh so you
might ask well how cold is it where the
sun don't shine oh how cold is it where
the sun don't sh hundreds of degrees
below zero that makes things difficult
doesn't it and so so this water which
would have arrived by comets you know
Moon's been hit by stuffe you didn't
notice the the the acne that's why the
man yeah that's why the man in the
moon's face looks like a pepperoni
pizza what a terrible shame the guy
looks like he's they got some serious
hormonal problems going on some teenage
acne issues a man in the moon is not
getting a date to the problem that's all
I'm saying it's gonna be tough really
it's rough it's rough need a little acan
so because there's atmosphere to smooth
out the hot places and the cold places
because what happens is in our air our
air sort of captures the heat once the
sun heats the ground and it moves that
around right bet doesn't happen on the
moon so uh where the sun is shining it's
200 degrees above zero you can sit out a
cup of water and boil it and in in the
where the sun doesn't shine it's
hundreds of degrees below zero really if
you're there the side of you facing the
Sun is going to be hot and the side of
you not facing the sun will rapidly cool
off so ideally you could go on a
rotisserie
right like Boston
chicken so but say there's a reason for
space suits to be reflective typically
okay because you want to be in full
control of what's going on so of course
they had you know those big packs that
were on the the the astronauts backs
half of that I don't know half but a big
part of it was the cooling system that
keeps them at the right temperature so
they don't bake or freeze nice and one
other thing before we end this uh
because there is no atmosphere that
means there's no
Skylight there's no Blue Sky in the
daytime the daytime sky is just dark all
right so the only source of light are
direct sight lines from the
Sun so if you're standing there
Chuck and you part of you is in
Shadow unless some light is reflecting
off the lunar terrain it is pitch dark
in the shadows of rocks and in your sha
pitch dark wow in broad daylight so that
makes for fascinating contrasty photos
when this happens yes you can get a
reflection off the of the lunar module
okay but the general ambient light we
take for granted when you walk around in
the daytime is not there on the moon
look at that yeah that's cool so so
Chuck there is no Dark Side of the Moon
that's all I got to tell you well there
you go Pink Floyd you're a bunch of
dummies so Chuck I was actually at a
party one day when I met Roger Waters
very cool yeah and you told him that
there was no dark side I had Chuck I had
to I couldn't remain silent and and what
what was his response he was not
sympathetic that makes sense he's like
bro I'm getting paid off this he got a
gravy train going yeah I got a nice
little racket going here with this Dark
Side of the Moon thing and you are
messing it up I'm going to need you to
silence I'm
gonna don't make me take out a gag order
on you
Neil but anyhow you know this the job of
the educator never ends I think that's
what's going on here as long as there
are forces of untruths that pervade the
world okay look how poetic you are I was
about to say as long as there are
ignorant dumb
asses the job of the educator shall not
be
finished all right that's all I got for
you on the dark side of the mov okay all
right all right as always I bid you to
keep looking
[Music]
up